Schon seit 1969 gibt es das internet damals ins leben gerufen durch das amerikanische verteidigungsministerium
und schon schnell vor allem als kommunikationsmittel zwischen forschungseinrichtungen benutzt
1989 wurde dann das world wide web am cern in genf entwickelt das über webseiten erstmals einfach
dokumente mit links darstellen konnte seitdem haben und meilensteine wie der internet explorer google wikipedia facebook
und natürlich auch youtube grundlegend geprägt doch wie wird sich das internet weiter entwickeln inwieweit
übernimmt künstliche intelligenz die kontrolle hier die vier spannendsten visionen über das internet der zukunft herzlich willkommen bei klicks um science-fiction
Nächste woche bin ich am cern dort wo sich der large hadron collider
der größte teilchenbeschleuniger der welt befindet und das world wide web wurde dort von tim
berners-lee erfunden der erste webserver
stand dort auch in form eines next cubes es war ein rechner den damals steve jobs in seiner firma next entwickelt hatte heute läuft eine
weiterentwicklung des betriebssystems
dieses rechners auf den modernen macs aber das ist eine andere geschichte kommen wir also zu den top 4
zukunftsvisionen für das internet es gibt nämlich mehrere perspektiven wohin die reise geht erste vision
künstliche intelligenz kontrolliert das internet die vierte industrielle revolution im internet
experten und expertinnen sind sich einig dass das netz schon bald
arbeiten automatisiert die bislang nur menschen ausführen konnten und zwar durch verschiedene anwendungen mit künstlicher intelligenz
und maschinellem lernen ganz fabriken können gesteuert werden die entwicklung von software geschieht automatisch
und auch eine medizinische diagnose
könnte demnächst direkt im netz stattfinden denn das ist auch klar die ki die künstliche intelligenz im netz kann sehr viel schneller
riesige datenbanken durchsuchen und abgleichen sowie muster erkennen
als wir menschen bleiben wir mal im medizinischen bereich denn tech firmen wie microsoft facebook amazon apple und google sind fest davon überzeugt
das verständnis von krankheiten sei letztlich ein daten problem das gelöst werden muss die instrumente
künstliche intelligenz und die analyse und auswertung riesiger datenmengen innerhalb kürzester zeit
dazu ein konkretes beispiel aus der praxis bei amazon geht es hauptsächlich um virtuelle
arztbesuche und darum wie sich riesige datenmengen im medizinischen bereich in einer cloud speichern lassen oder das microsoft projekt
hannover computer sollen sich zunächst einmal das komplette medizinische wissen aneignen heißt also
studien lesen und verstehen millionen von artikeln sind verfügbar und täglich kommen neue
erkenntnisse hinzu schier unmöglich für uns menschen kein großes problem dagegen für maschinen statt
einen wirkstoff nach dem anderen zu testen könnte intelligente software auf grundlage
der genomischen daten der patienten die literatur nach der perfekt
medikamentenkombination
durchsuchen auf einen schlag können so tausende von kombinationen analysiert werden und dem ärzte-team
vorgeschlagen werden durch die zusammenarbeit mit dem menschen könnten die maschinen dann sogar immer weiter dazulernen und ihre intelligenz
ausbauen und das ist nicht das einzige projekt das hoffnung macht ein bm hat eine ki entwickelt die die dna
sequenzierung eines gehirntumors schneller und zuverlässiger
analysiert hat als das gesamte team der menschlichen experten und expertinnen in israel arbeitet ein forschungsteam an einem virtuellen
gesundheits assistenten der die patienten und patientinnen im chat berät die maschine hat zugriff auf eine riesige datenbank
und allen aufnahme protokollen bei wunsch zudem auf die persönlichen daten der patienten und patientinnen
zweite visionen super schneller und zuverlässiger
internetzugang auf der gesamten erde
richtig gutes und schnelles netz haben wir hier in selbst in deutschland nur in bestimmten regionen und großstädten
in ländlichen gebieten der wüste
abgelegenen inseln oder gar dem dschungel sieht das ganz anders aus das will ihnen mast mit seinem raumfahrtunternehmen spacex
ändern und im laufe der nächsten jahre
kommunikationssatelliten in den niedrigen orbit schicken die die ganze welt umspannen so sollen alle an schnellen zugang zum internet
kommen dieses ziel haben und hatten auch andere doch der plan von mas übertrifft alle anderen projekte sowohl in seiner angepeilten
zuverlässigkeit verfügbarkeit
und dimensionen bis
2025 soll das ganze netz aufgebaut sein dessen konzept dann später so auch für den mars übernommen werden soll auch das unternehmen
bleibt hat ähnliche pläne und will ein netz aus knapp 900 satelliten aufbauen vielleicht gibt es in zukunft aber auch vermehrt
autonome netze also wlan
verbindungen die zwischen einzelnen smartphones
gebildet werden beispielsweise wo du nach dem schweren erdbeben in haiti ein messenger entwickelt der nachrichten über ein peer to peer netz
weiterleitet denn ja über weite strecken viel dort das gewöhnliche internets aus dieses konzept nutzt die möglichkeit moderne
telefone
gänzlich autonome mesch netze zu bilden das heißt also
selbst wenn das internet komplett ausfällt können handys tablets und computer dann ein eigenes
autonomes unabhängiges netz aufbauen dritte vision menschliche gehirne werden mit dem
internet verbunden wir haben darüber hierbei klicks und science fiction berichtet erst vor kurzem ist es am
forschungsteam tatsächlich gelungen zum ersten mal das menschliche gehirn mit dem internet zu verbinden und in zukunft sollen dann auch
daten wirklich auf unser gehirn übertragbar sein das experiment aus washington hat deutlich gemacht dass die
kommunikation zwischen zwei menschen die hirnströme über das internet austauschen schon jetzt
funktioniert und auch viele unternehmen haben genau diese vision
beispielsweise der unternehmer allen masc mit seiner firma neuling ja da mal wieder hätte das gedacht in seinen vorstellungen
können wir in einigen jahrzehnten elektronische
geräte direkt mit unserem gehirn verbinden und zwar mit hilfe implantierter
chips im hirn die bits und bytes in gedanken über setzen können und umgekehrt auch facebook hat ähnliche pläne
menschen sollen demnächst direkt aus dem gehirn heraus worte im computer schreiben lassen
100 worte pro minute das ist das ziel das forschungsteam von facebook seien nun dabei sehr
empfindliche sensoren zu entwickeln die die aktivität im gehirn sehr genau verfolgen können so wäre es dann auch nicht mehr notwendig die einzelnen buchstaben
im kopf zu bilden was zudem dazu führen könnte dass wir bald auch andere sprachen sprechen könnten und
zwar ohne sie vorher zu lernen der gedanke an einen behälter in der hand aus dem an flüssigkeit trinken kann
könnte dann direkt mit dem entsprechenden fremdwort für tasse auf japanisch oder
englisch umgesetzt werden falls dies alles funktioniert würde es die welt wie wir sie kennen komplett
umkrempeln anstatt eine e mail zu tippen würde es ausreichend einfach kurz an den gewünschten
inhalt zu denken der computer verwandelt unsere gedanken dann in den entsprechenden
text um zudem hätten wir zugriff auf die gedanken und erfahrungen anderer menschen so könnten wir also
problemlos die erfahrung von anderen erleben zb die eines promis oder eines soldaten
auch wenn wir bestimmte fachwissen haben wollen müssen wir nur an diesen wunschdenken und könnten schon den gedanken
entsprechender experten und expertinnen
herunterladen vierte visionen super sicheres internet durch quanten vielleicht hat das ja mitbekommen
ich war letztens an der uni in wien zum einen habe ich selbst dort einen vortrag gehalten zum anderen aber auch professor philip walther
einen der experten für quantenkryptographie weltweit kennen gelernt die forschung ist an der universität wien schon extrem weit seit mitte letzten jahres den
sind die hoffnungen groß in sachen quanten netz den chinesischen satelliten mikio sehen viele als den vorboten einer neuen ära
wenn er überträgt quanten verschränkte infrarot photonen daten statt radiowellen und das absolut abhörsicher im fachmagazin nature
vermeldete ein forschungsteam aus china dann das unfassbare
nicos war tatsächlich in der lage den wichtigsten schritt zu absolvieren die sogenannte
quantenkryptographie konkret heißt das dass der quanten code über eine distanz von rund
2500 kilometer zwischen peking und wien
ausgetauscht werden konnte und das auch noch bis zu 100 trillionen mal effizienter als ein glasfaser das ist wirklich ein absoluter meilenstein
werden tatsächlich lichtteilchen
übertragen nur wenn das einzelne teilchen ankommt funktioniert das system
nebel oder wolken können das komplett verhindern in einigen wenigen jahrzehnten könnte auf dieser basis ein quanten
satellitennetz entstehen das
absolute
abhörsichere kommunikation weltweit ermöglicht denn nur die quanten schüssel müssen über die satelliten übertragen werden die verschlüsselte kommunikation
funktioniert dann ganz normal über das internet denn das ganze läuft so falls der übertragende schlüssel abgefangen wird geht die
verschränkung der photonen kaputt und das merken sowohl sender als auch empfänger der schlüssel kann nicht verwendet werden
experten und expertinnen sind sie schon heute einig dass es schwierig sein wird die herrschaft im netz zu behalten nicht nur das militär
sondern auch geheimdienste oder kriminelle können die sicherheitslücken im internet nutzen um vorteile für sich herauszuholen
geld oder macht die quanten fotografie wäre ein wichtiger schritt zu einem sicheren netz
ja wenn ihr keine videos zur entwicklung des internets und zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollt dann endet mich bei whatsapp
dann um geht ihr die kaputte abo box hier auf youtube und verpasst kein video denn über whatsapp
erfahrt ihr von mir noch vor allen anderen vom neuesten video täglich und garantiert einfach hier draufklicken
und am besten auch meinen schwesterkanal klicks um social and media abonnieren da gibt es das neueste
aus der social media welt dafür hier klicken aber nicht ganz wichtig die
genau die glocke vergessen und hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken online überholt fernsehen bis dann
bleibt dran